if things keep up as they are and Trump
is the nominee and if Trump somehow
manages to make it through and become
the president again what if DeSantis
were the chief of staff okay I'm
listening you have
you know it seems crazy I know you said
why would Rhonda say this one be the
chief of staff well because DeSantis is
clearly a policy wonk DeSantis is
clearly good at pulling the levers of
power getting things done sometimes
behind the scenes these are things that
Trump is not necessarily interested in
Trump is a world historic figure Trump
likes the big picture Trump likes the
cameras Trump likes talking Trump
doesn't always like the the details in
the minutia of the Personnel decisions
Trump doesn't always like the details in
minutia of the policy decisions and so
what if you had a president Trump and a
white house chief of staff Ronda santis
white house chief of staff in many ways
is the most powerful person in the world
most powerful person in Washington and
therefore in the whole world working on
all this little Personnel the minutia
the policy